hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update sony has just announced that
global sales of the PlayStation 4 have
exceeded 7 million units along with the
announcement Andrew house president and
group CEO of sony computer entertainment
wrote in a press release the response
from the global gaming community for ps4
has been overwhelming and we are truly
humbled the gamers are selecting ps4 as
their next-generation console of choice
the ps4 journey has just begun and
although we are still facing
difficulties keeping up with a strong
demand worldwide we remain steadfast in
our commitment to meet the needs of our
customers and surpassing the wildest
expectations of gamers by delivering new
user experiences that inspire and engage
we look forward to unveiling many of
these experiences to our fans in the
coming months the press release also
stated the global software sales for ps4
have passed 20.5 million copies for both
digital and physical media NPD numbers
are expected to arrive later this week
which will give us a better picture of
how these numbers stack up against the
competition but it's great news for Sony
and for gamers that their console
continues to push such huge numbers for
all the details on the NPD numbers as
they're released as well as your Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 news be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot com